on October 28th friends family co-stars
and fans came together to honor The Life
and Legacy of Matthew Perry the friends
favorite who famously portrayed Chand Le
Bing throughout the Beloved sitcom's
entire run died that day at the age of
54 just under a week later on November
3rd the actor's funeral took place at
Forest Law Memorial Park in Los Angeles
California as it turns out the service
which Perry's friends castmates David
Schwimmer Jennifer Aniston Courtney Cox
Lisa cudro and Matt lablanc attended
it's immensely significant in terms of
its location for those unfamiliar with
Forest Law Memorial Park or Los Angeles
at large the cemetery is located in
close proximity to somewhere Perry spent
a lot of time between 1994 and 2004 not
far as the LA Warner Brothers studi lot
where numerous legendary Friends
episodes and scenes were filmed during
its 10 seasons on the airwaves however
to sell audiences on the idea that the
series takes place in New York City the
thoughtfully designed sets were coupled
with establishing shots of real New York
locals additionally it's worth noting
that the cemetery itself Forest Law
Memorial Park is significant for
containing the grave sites of countless
other entertainment icons according to
the Forest Lawn website the funeral
service provider has been active in
Southern California for over a century
it has multiple locations within that
region with Forest Lawn Memorial Park in
Los Angeles Hollywood Hills being the
second oldest of the more considering
how long it has been in existence and
the area that it operates within it's no
surprise that Matthew Perry isn't the
first celebrity to be laid to rest there
in fact it contains the graves of
notable entertainment names dating back
to the early days of film and television
over the years actors such as Carrie
fiser and Michael Clark Duncan and
directors like Metropolis Mastermind
Fritz L and Return of the Jedi Helmer
Richard marand have entered Forest Law
Memorial Park in the 2020s alone Sex in
the City staple Willie garon comedian
Fred Willard and even long time the
Price's right host Bob Barker to the
name a few have been interred there thus
between its status as a graveyard pretty
much dedicated to entertainers and its
closeness to the main filming location
of friends is a perfectly fitting
resting place for Perry with news of
Matthew Perry's Funeral reaching the
internet folks around the world have
kept up their appreciation of him
naturally many have continued sharing
their favorite Chan the Bing lines
moments and Friends episodes on social
media after all friends is Perry's most
well-known entertainment Endeavor and
Chandler is a role he has become
synonymous with however being remembered
for a specific project or character
wasn't his top priority as he explained
during an appearance on Q as Tom power
throughout his life Perry didn't shy
away from sharing his experience with
alcohol and substance use disorders he
also made it clear that he wanted to
help those in similar situations in any
way he could an effort that meant a lot
to him he said when I die I don't want
friends to be the first thing that's
mentioned I want my desire to help
people with substance abuse issues to be
the first thing that's mentioned and I'm
going to live the rest of my life
proving that I would like to be
remembered as somebody who lived well
loved well was a seeker and just
Paramount things that he wants to help
people in the wake of his death in
funeral Matthew Perry will be fnally
remembered as both a skilled actor as
well as a selfless human being may he
rest in peace if you or anyone you know
needs help with addiction issues help is
available visit the Substance Abuse and
Mental Health Services Administration
website or contact samsa's National
helpl line that's 1800 662 help 4357